the non-binary X Biden official Sam
Britton was on a secret taxpayer funded
trip at the time of his luggage theft
what an unbelievably fun story here so
yes Sam Britton of the Department of
energy was on a tax-funded trip at the
time when he stole the luggage that was
or the incident where it was actually
captured on footage in Nevada Nevada I
can't believe I said Nevada who says
Nevada it's Nevada no it's Nevada okay I
don't know it was like a speech
impediment there for a moment that's
Nevada um but yeah so the trip was
caught on camera I believe this is the
the third time or at least he's been
accused three times of taking suitcases
from women
um and then wearing he's been convicted
of this one out of three so it wasn't
enough that he was on a taxpayer-funded
trip he also had to get free luggage so
I guess one question I have is does this
guy just not pack a bag before he goes
on these trips and maybe the reason that
like he's ended up just just wearing
different clothing isn't just uh you
know like self-expression as he would
put it but it's like this is what's in
the luggage you just get luggage from
the airport and then you put the clothes
on and like the clothing that was in the
luggage well even how much is he
stealing to continually find clothes
that fit like is he just playing a
numbers game or is he doing the Buffalo
Bill thing of where he'll go are you
about size 14 club and then get the what
no I have no idea but I don't think he's
spending all that much time thinking
about the luggage he gets because there
was a hilarious story a little while ago
Hannah Claire and I were talking about
this before uh we we went on air but it
was basically determined that the
clothing that he was wearing was
clothing which came from the suitcase of
a woman who was a fashion designer yeah
so she had made a bunch of different uh
beautiful dresses for a fashion Expo she
went from Tanzania she's from Tanzania
which is based in Houston
and traveled to DC was supposed to show
her clothes as sort of a business deal
for her and couldn't do it because her
bag went missing at Reagan Airport and
uh when she heard about Sam Britain's
arrest she said I'm going to look this
up and recognize the clothes that he has
been wearing because they're not just
run of the mill you can get them at the
Gap they are very unique meanwhile so
she went on Twitter for this and I was
just like I I was shortly thereafter
contacted by the FBI who was like please
give us more information and then after
that I I don't know if they're actually
connected but uh Sam Burton was arrested
as a fugitive from Justice he lives in
Maryland because he works for DC in
connection to someone's luggage going
missing from a DC airport and I find
this to be so funny because what were
the odds I mean it wasn't like he just
wore them you know casually to the
office he went on to like the Trevor
projects had him on for some some award
and he's wearing this thing can you
imagine being this woman being like I
not just own that I made that that is my
piece of clothing but shouldn't we as a
nation all share with one another Hannah
Claire I don't don't you think it's a
bit stingy of her to say
you didn't build that uh somebody else
made that happen my I quote Norm
Macdonald here and that sounds like some
bleep commy gobbledygook um I'd also
like to draw attention to San Bruno
again I'm just gonna go on the ad
hominemian because you're setting a
fantastic example that that mug shot is
the sleep paralysis demon though my name
is
Matt Damon could play that guy he's a
little older now but then what do you
want to do you think it could be could
be an interesting kind of Thriller yeah
dude Lex Friedman made a hilarious
observation it wasn't even a joke he's
like you go to the airport you wait for
two hours standing in line taking your
shoes off taking your bag out and then
when you get out of the airport you get
all done just take whatever bag you want
yeah and it's true there's like you
could you could walk out of there with
like 40 bags I mean not if you have more
than one someone will probably be like
hey but there's no security at the bags
they just come out and anyone can grab
anything it's crazy you know what though
I hear you but please don't give them a
donation to make the airport more of a
hassle with that like I think the
baggage thing is us saying this is a
this is a price we are willing to pay to
just not have to deal with the TSA
anymore not have to deal with any more
bureaucracy just let me go I'm off the
plane let me leave but we didn't even
need that level of bureaucracy when we
were high across society and when we
started mainstreaming degeneracy and
importing compatible cultures where High
trust is not that same thing the social
texture phrase so you need increasing
levels of bureaucracy to micromanage the
behaviors of a dependent population and
I I would agree with you but it's not
even just that I mean these
bureaucracies aren't even effective at
combating what they're there to protect
us from the TSA has failed like 98 of
its audits to try to press off by
incompetent diversity hires like this so
unfortunately they decide to out
themselves I mean yeah if he is one of
one of our leading nuclear Minds in this
country I don't know what you're talking
about oh yeah he lots of his head from
the radiation Point yeah seriously no
one I mean I think it's worth pointing
out that uh you're saying before is he
just following people around and
guessing that they're his size he is he
is specifically uh looking for female
luggage one one of the examples was uh
he stole a a duffel bag what I believe
was Vera Bradley if you if you know Vera
Bradley it's all very feminine prints
this person is specifically targeting
women to steal from them this is bizarre
and yet the Biden Administration just
tried to pretend it wasn't happening
they sort of said oh well not employed
by us like we couldn't say and now we
know that actually he was acting this
way while on duty for the government
well look I mean come on stealing
luggage sniffing kids they're not that
far outside of one another in terms of
like a Defiance of normal behavioral
expectations so I I I I don't even think
it's the body administration's worst
Scandal by any stretch of the United
States not the weirdest thing and by
scale I'm not saying well there were
scandals because there's political
option now I'm just talking about like
the weird things people in the Biden
Administration have done I don't think
this is the weirdest thing we have a
vice president who cackles over Venn
diagrams and who loves yellow school
buses and gleefully exclaims it like
she's a children's population
control they put satanists in charge
with monkey pox response I mean did they
well this is yeah this is I mean and of
course the monkey pox thing we won't get
too much into detail about that just
because uh probably says if it is a
family-friendly show but I just find it
interesting that the thing is that is
associated with the spread of monkey pox
was like the one thing that we were not
willing to prohibit because we believe
so deeply in human freedom and political
Liberty when we were willing to tell
people not to go to their jobs or to
visit loved ones in the hospital or
attend funerals for loved ones during
the covet pandemic it just shows you
where the priorities of the regime are
we just don't want to be big at it I
mean I think it's worth noting we still
talked about this before the show but
Sanford is openly I don't know gender
fluid all all sorts of interesting
hobbies he was featured in like a kink
magazine uh I find it
not at all surprising that this person
is clearly not bound by any social norms
or values exhibitionist kleptomaniac
right yes okay that's important open
about this uh he does not believe in the
world that you live in he does not
believe in uh anything else I'm sure I
am getting his pronouns wrong
of course he's stealing bags everywhere
this this last like moment of trust that
we all take our own bags off the
carousel does not not apply to him
because he doesn't need to be a part of
that and it's hard for me not to read a
level of entitlement into this yeah a
level of entitlement I mean I think
that's true whenever you see somebody
defying social expectations which are
otherwise otherwise reasonable and uh
acceptable makes sense every now and
again I get that there are barriers that
need to be broken down right you know I
like the idea of chesterton's fence when
you find a fence figure out what it was
for before you tear it down and
sometimes you know maybe that fence is
for something bad it's okay to tear it
down I'm not saying no one should ever
defy expectation but what I am saying is
when someone is defying expectations
when they're tearing down fences that
very clearly have a person of course
there's a sense of entitlement there do
you guys know what happened to Sam
Britton or what his status is right now
is he arrested and he got arrested at
his home in Maryland most recently so
with the the bag stolen in Vegas there
were uh he was convicted he had to pay
uh fine in Minnesota a similar thing
brought up on charges there was a fine
but also he had to undergo mental health
uh evaluations as part of sort of a a
deal to to lessen the charges against
him I haven't gotten an update on what
happened with with the arrest in
Maryland which is connected to the DC
airport which presumably is this woman
in Houston unless there are more missing
bags that we don't know about he said he
fled he was a per he was a a fugitive
Justice that was the that was what he
was arrested under and I'm not sure I
see I'm surprised he had to undergo
mental health examination because I can
just take one look at him and see he's
clearly soon I mean yeah yeah I think
that's why they're like how can such a
sane healthy individual like you get
into stealing bags we just can't
understand so we actually in Britain
have had two recent scandals of um
married men with children who have been
on TV stations for a very long time one
was a news reader the other one hosted a
daytime TV show
um they have claimed mental health
scares once they've been caught trying
to solicit photos or hook up with young
men of teenage questionable age wow yes
and uh one of them tried to get out
ahead of it about a year and a half ago
by saying that I am coming out as gay
and isn't this Brave and then it turns
out that he was having an affair turns
out with someone on the set so you have
to come out as as brave because yeah
otherwise you might think I'm a terrible
Creed yeah exactly and what they end up
doing is they Retreat into saying oh um
this is one it's homophobic to criticize
this and two I've been checked into the
hospital for a mental health emergency
so we're going to leave this story alone
for a while yeah you have to leave me
alone this is another important part of
it right I mean look it no one is like
making the argument that every single
person who struggles with any kind of uh
perversion is trying to attack children
but the reality is if you have they them
pronouns next to your name any predatory
behavior that you engage in is going to
be defended by the median by the left
and anyone who points out that you're
doing something suspicious is going to
be labeled a bigot but it's at some
point you have to action speak for
themselves it that is the way of the
world that is if we want to survive as a
species you cannot be like well you hurt
all those people okay like no man if you
if you if if something you didn't this
goes for leadership as well if something
you did causes maybe a surrender now
Afghanistan and the death of children
and and people trying to flee the
country being beheaded like you're on
the hook for that you can't just be like
oh I was 85 years old and I wasn't
thinking about it like they I I
I want some I want some responsibility
for these behaviors and this is I have
empathy for people with mental health
issues for sure but at some point
there's no you've got to be realistic
about it yeah I mean I I have compassion
for people who have mental health issues
I don't have like that much compassion
for the people who elect them thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time